hello reject nation Greg Alba here and
I'm John so we've heard a lot about this
Cloverfield paradox but actually not a
lot a lot about the market I heard if
people hate it or like it we thought
like you know what it's about time we
watch it because we're later than
everyone else for this movie no one was
expecting to watch this we might be late
to the party we're gonna watch it
Netflix it can get pretty strict about
what you feature and for a movie don't
think we can get away with show YouTube
what we're gonna do here is we're just
gonna do the whole reaction for our
folks over at patreon if you want to
check it out is not a Clickbank video
because this video is only titled review
so don't give us [ __ ] about it alright
we haven't seen it yet but right now
we're gonna do a reaction for it then
right afterwards we'll give an instant
review of the film and that's where
you're gonna watch right here right now
unless you go over our patreon first and
you know this goes alright haha see you
in a second alright we're literally just
watching it that's right we just wrapped
up the Cloverfield paradox I'll tell you
guys a quick recap of our experience
watching this movie when it started I
was like too bad I could see how could
potentially get worse I mean in pretty
quick but mostly with cool stuff yeah
early comments I think I was making you
know I can see how if this isn't the
theaters this would be annoying because
they had an opening of the couple in the
car waiting in traffic cuts the space
and then there'd montaging over some
other mission in space what cut him in
between the credits and I was like in a
movie theater this to feel jarring and
off but I think on TV it's fine
that is the movie progressed I was like
ah now this is this is just not a
well-written movie this is not a good
movie the movie it's super intermittent
but it was only interesting when they
had like cool sequences going you know
I'm like space-time kookiness is going
down
that's easy to get into when like the
intensity of ramps up cuz something's
scary however that's cool but even a
thing is written well enough to generate
any real suspense there's no word
catharsis there's no real cool mystery
to it just the looming idea that
probably more weird stuff might happen
and and the linking it to Cloverfield
felt odd Ness
Ceri to me all time we're watching the
storyline with Roger Davies on earth
who's experiencing the Cloverfield thing
going on that we saw from the first
movie I kept hoping it would add up to
something more and I kept saying that
during the reaction I was like I just
really hope this pays off and it doesn't
really pay off it's more like we didn't
need to keep cutting back to this just
helps out a little girl there's no like
arc to the whole thing and I felt like
with the main character Hamilton I don't
even really get what her arc is it's if
they like had this whole final moment
with her where she's sending a message
to herself at the end and I'm like does
she art she decided which her her loss
is real and Dyson to go back and
severely destroy Spacey yeah I like
going back and trying to connect with
mrs. so many opportunities to like dive
into it's cool sci-fi stuff and that
also sort of stunts the coolness of
everything because if there's one thing
he has coolness yeah but yeah nobody
ever takes the time to stop and talk
about just about anything majority of
the movie could have been fixed if he
had Act one you just get to know the
characters yeah if anybody talked about
anything that wasn't the plot yeah just
get to know the characters but every
this felt like an outline it felt like a
like a specific outline the outline that
I was thinking of was they came up with
some cool set sequences like Oh
Christopher Davis is armed trapped in
here that looks cool the putty or let's
let's reference you know because we're a
space movie let's pay tribute to alien
literally who thought he was gonna have
a chest birth scene the Russian guy in
the movie pretty much a chess person
yeah I'm thing that shouldn't be there
pops out of it like you start earth do
you think he dies and something pops out
it's gross and it's cool yeah it pales
when it's for nothing other than like oh
yeah that's familiar
and zhuangzi's death that was cool when
like the water always the sequences are
cool the promise everything in between
that there's no good character scenes in
here they're really family ridden and
moments where actors will be on-screen
together and there will just be long
pauses and I'm like yeah opportunities
you could have had to have character at
this thing I also didn't like the way
characters would respond to things or
not did not response or respond to
things okay like woman appearing in the
wall cool thing that was neat and then
like she's sucked and she was like best
I mean they probably had some flash card
if this would be a cool thing to do but
then the way it plays out or Shizuo
touch where she's like Schmidt is the
one who's screwed everyone over there
was already clearly some weird [ __ ]
going on this woman knows who Hamilton
is this woman knows who the crew is the
captain just reads like a couple of logs
and it just starts punching Daniel it
doesn't take a moment to slow down a go
something might be off here in the
audience seat I'm medially going dude
slow down for a second and start asking
yourself a question you wish everybody
would just get acclimated to how weird
everything is because like some pretty
weird [ __ ] starts happening pretty quick
to the point where I feel like any group
of humans would be like hey yeah we got
to confer about this instead of
believing the first thing we hear each
time and then going to punch somebody
yeah the plot just seems to like need to
get where it's going it's too choppy and
I feel like it's probably wanting to go
for this immediate vibe I've just throw
yourself into the situation of these
characters let it be this ticking time
clock of an intense experience in space
but that's the exact opposite of what I
feel because I don't get time to hang to
know these characters at all I feel like
they were trying to do a Dunkirk thing
with this but it's not effective in here
so as killing it's all character moment
even when the scenes aren't very
dialogue heavy you're still paying
attention to like body language and
stuff and this movie just like
occasionally shows you people feeling
things there's a lot of repetition of
repeating the plot reminding us of
what's going on there are a few times
where we actually commented out loud we
were like no no I know I just saw that
if you took all those lines and compiled
them that's probably a monologues worth
it leads to better dialogue that could
out there this movie would have certain
scenes where they would attempt to have
character moments and the one there was
one good scene I could think of Hamilton
is talking with Jensen and Jensen
showing the footage of like hey your
family and my earth is still alive yeah
that stuff was that was a good scene the
issue that I had I think I made a
comment a lot of this would be way more
effective if I actually gave a [ __ ]
about these guys before movies is
intermittent in almost every department
whenever a randomly kind of rich
emotional moment pops up it's also
jarring because you're like I know this
is gonna go away half a second like what
zhang ziyi died you even said that like
they're gonna just move past this like
right away even though his character is
super important to daniel bruhl
character no time for any remorse or
sadness just pop up to the next plot
things montón this literally was
watching an outline it reminded me of a
slasher movie in that way it's like some
weird space-time stuff shows up every
now and again to do like a cool death
scene and then we just kind of breeze
past it and like the toll of this like
for a movie that wants you to believe
that like oh they're missing a fan back
home and they're all stuck together
they've known each other for years and
now this all doesn't add up like you
can't feel any of that history or
anything it's cool to look at and
there's a lot of great ideas and neat
shots I don't really care I just and and
and breezing like plowing through the
plot like that yeah you you just need a
certain amount of counterweight for that
you need a certain amount of care
because otherwise there is no suspense
and I was waiting for how this turns out
cool ideas all around that they put down
on on their outline here I feel like
this could have been fine with just a
lot of character like give it an extra
like 20 minutes and you would have been
fine to rewrite some of the scenes and
you would have been fine there's a lot
even just like let the act one play out
a little slower so that way you could
just build into stuff instead of just
rushing to we're no we're just gonna get
too exciting [ __ ] right away even the
ending of this film the finale when it
comes to Jensen betraying them like that
was so stupid to me and cliche because
it plays out like just
wanna be alien and wants to be sunshine
this whole movie felt like it wants to
be this other once you have been her
Ozzy aliens overfilled of our should be
life wants to be gravity and the whole
movie just kept feeling like other
things to me yeah and the Cloverfield
stuff feels a little bit forced in here
it's kind of cool to get some
information is all right cuz in this one
I felt they kind of woven throughout
words even in 10 Cloverfield Lane it
feels like a thing that's sort of
attached to the end you know whereas
this one like they do at least kind of
address it and sort of broaden out like
it's it's apparently like a Space
Station I like that what they're
expanding is this weird sci-fi
space-time rip that means multiple
things it's not only monster movie but
it's also oh there's another earth and
things are different there I like my
aspiration was I like the idea of how
yeah they wanted a handle yeah your
exact when you first when he first sees
like the monster in the shadows I mean
when Michael rescues a little white girl
that was cool like building it up but
the thing is his plot line doesn't
really pay out no it's just a plot no
yeah it's got it's filled with cool
ideas that could have worked as a good
Cloverfield movie and a terrible
resolution of an ending to me cool that
the monster shows up and that that was a
jump moment for us we were like whoa
finally a kind of intense finale but
that I hated that it just ends there
that no there's no true resolution for
the one character that we were focusing
in on it's just her husband going
don't like the payoff to it man I would
say for the most part it was fun to
watch I think like the last half hour I
was really like man I can't wait for
this movie to wrap up I'm getting kind
of bored right now because nothing
really holds it was that's a day when it
was clear wasn't gonna pick up her
Chaney ace at all yeah it's a
predictable script of predictable
moments wasted cally all the cast ass is
wasted man it's a great cast and they're
wasted Oh another moment I got to point
out with Chris O'Dowd I hated was when
he sees his arms cut off and the way he
reacts to that first time yeah was so
bad yeah and I know that wasn't Chris
O'Dowd fault that was the writing in the
dirt should write that in there
the house done anyone who lost their arm
and diamond will be in shock or scared
yeah something yeah and they establish
moments later that it doesn't feel like
it ought to either so like there's so
much out of the crazy [ __ ] they keep
seeing in this movie you'd think
somebody would freak out a little hard
they tried implementing a moment of
humor that just felt totally off it's
just wrong for let's see this movie
doesn't have there's a follow up moment
that does work I mean they don't let
moments truly play out the only parts
that are really edited well or the cool
sci-fi sequences when when these things
collide and whatnot but that's not the
majority of because it has everything
and it's all there all the potential
just needs some expansion rewrite so
much but like I like the direction I
like the idea I like most of what they
wanted to do and yeah it just doesn't
come together it's like a good movie
it's like it could have been like a more
horror version of like interstellar
meets sunshine yeah yeah yeah man if I
were to give a consensus on this man I
would say it's not necessary to watch
this movie really unless unless just
cool [ __ ] is enough for you yeah looks
amazing there's a lot of great design
work it's great to look at and it's got
that sort of Twilight Zone ease all
right guys yeah you can catch our
reaction to this over at patreon and in
the meantime you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up and yeah see you on the
flippety-flip